the fact that a man who is designed by
multiple women is seen as desirable on
average by more women it's the reason
why guys should have photos on their
Tinder profile with them with other
women because it shows that you're not
like a total basement dweller some women
think I'm cool yeah exactly I'm not
totally repulsive to women because of
that if a woman does start trying to
call out a man's exploits because it is
probably positive expected value on his
status it's a pointless thing it only
makes him look better yeah exactly think
about like the insults that get thrown
around on the internet the first one
from any woman or man to a woman is and
the first one from any man or woman to a
man is awesome right so it's disparaging
a lack of Chastity on one side and a
lack of actual experience on the other
because those are the most valuable
things that they have to offer